>> AND SO THE KIA DEFENSIVE
PLAYER OF THE YEAR, THERE HE IS,
RUDY GOBERT, WE JOIN YOUR
TEAMMATES APPLAUDING THIS, A
THIRD TIME IN THE LAST FOUR
YEARS FOR YOU.
THEY GOT QUITE THE SET UP FOR
YOU, RUDY, THEY'VE DONE THIS UP
BIG TIME THERE IN SALT LAKE
CITY, WOW, HOW ABOUT THAT.
>> WHOA THAT IS KIND OF COOL
THERE.
>> YEAH, VERY NICE.
SO, LET ME ASK THE FIRST
QUESTION.
AND PART OF IT IS REALLY A
STATEMENT, JUST SEEMS
APPROPRIATE, RUDY, THAT YOU ARE
GIVEN THIS AWARD FOR THE THIRD
TIME.
LESS THAN 24 HOURS AFTER A HUGE
DEFENSIVE PLAY THAT SEALED THE
WIN AGAINST THE CLIPPERS.
TAKE ME THROUGH IT.
>> I MEAN, WE -- WE WERE UP
THREE, SO WE KNOW THAT THEY'RE
LOOKING FOR A FREQUENT SHOT
OBVIOUSLY.
DID AMAZING JOB SWITCHING ON THE
DHO AND JOE WAS JUST AMAZING
TAKING AWAY THE THREE FROM
KAWHI, AND YOU KNOW, JUST SWUNG
THE BALL TO MAURICE AND WAS
OPEN, SO I HAD TO RYE TO GIVE
THE BEST CONTEST THAT I COULD.
>> CONGRATULATIONS ON ANOTHER
FABULOUS YEAR.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THREE TIME DEFENSIVE PLAYER
OF THE YEAR.
WHAT TYPE OF MENTALITY DOES IT
TAKE TO BE THE DEFENSIVE PLAYER
OF THE YEAR.
CHARLES CHARLES COULDN'T PLAY
DEFENSE, I COULDN'T PLAY
DEFENSE, BUT YOU WON IT THREE
TIMES IN A ROW, WHAT TYPE OF
MENTALITY TO SIGH I'M GOING TO
BE THE DEFENSIVE PLAYER OF THE
YEAR.
>> I THINK IT TAKES TEAM EFFORT.
YOU KNOW, IT TAKES TOUGHNESS,
MENTAL TOUGHNESS.
YOU KNOW, IT'S JUST HARD WORK,
DEDICATION, YOU KNOW, IT'S EVERY
SINGLE DAY GOT TO COME IN WITH
THAT MINDSET TO TRY IT MAKE YOUR
TEAM AS GOOD AS IT CAN BE ON
THAT END.
AND YOU KNOW, HAVE AN
ORGANIZATION, COACHING STAFF, MY
TEAMMATE THAT'S BELIEVE IN ME
EVERY SINGLE NIGHT.
nd I GIVE THEM THAT CONFIDENCE
BACK.
AND WE DO IT TOGETHER.
YOU KNOW.
WE'RE ABLE TO DO IT FOR MANY,
MANY YEARS.
SO IT'S A BLESSING.
>> RUDY, NUMBER ONE,
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> SECONDLY, UTAH JAZZ, NUMBER
ONE SEED IN THE WESTERN
CONFERENCE, THE FAVORITE, HOW
ARE YOU WEARING THAT TITLE?
>> I MEAN, WE -- WE DON'T FEEL
LIKE WE ACCOMPLISHED MUCH YET.
YOU KNOW, OBVIOUSLY IT'S BEEN A
GREAT YEAR, WE'VE NEVER FINISHED
FIRST IN THE NBA SINCE I'VE BEEN
HERE SO IT'S BEEN AN AMAZING
SEASON BUT WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE
A HIGHER GOAL, IT'S TO WIN THE
CHAMPIONSHIP.
YOU KNOW, WE WANT TO KEEP -- YOU
KNOW, KEEP PLAYING THE WAY WE
KNOW WE CAN PLAY DURING THE
PLAYOFFS AND HOPEFULLY WE GET AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PLAY FOR THAT
BECAUSE THAT'S THE BEST OF THE
ACCOMPLISHMENT WE CAN GET AS A
TEAM.
>> RUDY, I HAVE A TWO-PART
QUESTION, FIRST IS, YOU KNOW,
THEY ALWAYS SAY IT TAKES A LOT
OF EFFORT OBVIOUSLY TO PLAY
DEFENSE, WOULD YOU SAY IT'S MORE
EFFORT OR MORE STRATEGY IN TERMS
OF KNOWING WHAT TO DO ON THE
DEFENSIVE END?
THAT'S THE FIRST PART AND THEN
I'LL ASK THE SECOND.
>> I MEAN, IT'S BOTH, YOU KNOW,
YOU -- YOU KNOW, YOU GUYS KNOW,
YOU'VE BEEN IN THIS FOR A WHILE,
YOU KNOW, THERE'S SOME
STANDARDS.
EVERY SINGLE NIGHT SOMEONE'S
TRYING TO COME AT YOU, GOOD
TEAMS AND BAD TEAMS, TEAMS ARE
TRYING TO COME AT YOU AND SCORE.
WE PLAY IN THE LEAGUE TODAY,
IT'S REALLY ORIENTED ON THE
OFFENSIVE SIDE OF THE BALL.
YOU KNOW, WE GOT SO MUCH TALENT
THAT FOR ME IT'S EVERY SINGLE
DAY, I KNOW THAT, YOU KNOW, IT'S
GOING TO BE A BATTLE AND A
CHALLENGE.
SO I'VE KIND OF EMBRACED THAT
OVER THE YEARS AND LIKE I SAID,
YOU KNOW, HAVING COACH QUINN
SNYDER BEHIND ME AND ALL OF THE
GUYS PUSHING ME EVERY DAY HAS
BEEN EXCITING ANDS BEEN AMAZING.
I DON'T TAKE NONE OF THAT FOR
GRANTED.
>> AND MY SECOND PART, I PLAYED
WITH A GUY IN HIGH SCHOOL WHO
WAS A GREAT DEFENSIVE PLAYER IN
THE AU AND EVERYTHING AND ONLY
THING HE SAID TO ME, I WAS LIKE,
MAN YOU PLAY SUCH GREAT D, HE
SAID YOU KNOW WHAT THOUGH, I'D
RATHER GET 40 THAN PLAY IT D,
KENNY.
SO I WILL ASK YOU THE QUESTION,
IF YOU HAD THE CHANCE TO GET 50
IN A GAME OR 15 BLOCKS IN A
GAME, WHICH WOULD YOU TAKE?
AS A DEFENSIVE PLAYER OF THE
YEAR.
>> I MEAN, I'LL TAKE THE WIN.
YOU KNOW.
BUT, IP THINK 15 BLOCKS, I DON'T
KNOW IF ANYONE'S DONE THAT
BEFORE.
50 POINTS IS PRETTY COOL TOO,
SO, WHATEVER HAS MY TEAM
WINNING, WHATEVER HAS MY TEAM --
YOU KNOW, AT THE END THE DAY,
EVERYTHING I DO IS TO TRY TO
HELP MY TEAM WIN AND YOU KNOW,
WHETHER I HAVE TO SET SCREENS OR
GO TO THE BASKET, PLAY DEFENSE,
I'M TRYING TO DO EVERYTHING I
CAN TO WIN.
THAT'S THE BOTTOM LINE.
>> RUDY, LAST THING FROM THIS
END, AND THIS IS JUST SOMETHING
I FIND INTERESTING WITH ALL OF
THE AWARD-WINNERS THAT WE TALK
TO.
IS THAT, WHEN YOU CONSIDER THIS
AWARD NOW IT'S THREE TIMES,
WHERE DOES YOUR MIND GO?
WHO DO YOU THINK ABOUT WHO MADE
THIS POSSIBLE?
WHO HAD THE BIGGEST IMPACT ON
YOU, WHO INSTILLED CONFIDENCE
AND ABILITY AND WILL AND THAT
KIND OF THING.
>> MY MOM.
YOU KNOW.
SHE SACRIFICED A LOT FOR ME TO
BE ABLE TO DO WHAT I LOVE.
SHE BELIEVED IN ME AS A KID.
AND YOU KNOW, SHE ALLOWED ME TO,
YOU KNOW, DO WHAT I LOVE TO DO
AND DO WHAT I WANTED TO DO.
YOU KNOW, I WASN'T -- YOU KNOW,
I GREW UP IN A SMALL TOWN IN
FRANCE, I WASN'T REALLY SUPPOSED
TO BE HERE. IF YOU WOULD HAVE
ASKED ME WHEN I STARTED
BASKETBALL IF YOU WOULD HAVE
ASKED ME IF I WAS GONNA WIN
DEFENSIVE PLAYER OF THE YEAR, I
WOULD HAVE PROBABLY NOT BELIEVED
IT, BUT THREE OF THEM, YOU KNOW,
IT'S JUST AMAZING.
YOU KNOW.
IT'S ALL HER.
SHE GAVE ME EVERYTHING.
SHE TAUGHT ME HOW TO BE A GOOD
PERSON AND, YOU KNOW, I WOULDN'T
BE THERE WITHOUT HER.
>> WOW, RUDY GOBERT,
CONGRATULATIONS, MAN, WE'RE
HAPPY FOR YOU.
AND WE WISH YOU THE BEST.
DOWN THE ROAD IN THE NBA
PLAYOFFS.
RUDY GOBERT,